i just think he's so
let's serve up some news sunny side up
the daily mail reports that there's a
new time saving trend making the tick
tock rounds the next time you go grocery
shopping instead of paper or plastic try
a laundry basket that's right you can
use it to shop then check out and just
load it on back
into your car plop it down then you can
take it out and throw it right back in
your house and this solves the old like
soups can roll around problem or the bag
breaking who's in for this huh
um
you you love this
i
live for a laundry basket
i love
laundry i know you do it's so weird i
love it about you love it um i i could
okay i kind of get how this works i i
don't know that i i don't know i'll try
this but i will tell you this i do hate
paying the 10 cents for a bag at the
grocery store so i'll do i mean even
here in the city i'll do whatever it
takes to avoid it so i will carry like
garbanzo beans tuna fish a bottle of
fresca i will carry it eight blocks just
to avoid carrying a bag so maybe i
should just bring a laundry basket
the detroit news reports hometown hero m
m has just opened a brand new restaurant
called
mom's spaghetti it's inspired by a
famous lyrics from lose yourself and the
song from eight mile and today we do
have mom spaghetti right here uh it's an
interesting take on the classic they
serve it reheat style they cook the
pasta before and then they heat it up in
a wok for that leftover feel this is a
tv exclusive we have this is really it
from detroit okay mom
now listen
i've always thought that the only thing
better than italian food is leftover
reheated italian food so i'm thank you
i'm all about
all right okay
okay
that was really good okay really really
good
really good this is so incredible you
want a meatball to taste like that
classic
why they got to put the camera on me
when i'm taking the big bite
oh i stuffed an entire ball in my
i mouth you
i love him so much like i think he's
like
the greatest yeah who's fantastic like
he's my goat i gotta tell i just think
he's so
uh
we've got to talk about neighbors
we've all got them
uh but are you best buds with them
are you strangers do you avoid them
what's your deal with your neighbors
because town and country reports that
before the pandemic data showed that 30
of people were friends with their
neighbors while at the other extreme 30
percent
said they were total strangers but a
more recent study found that during the
pandemic one out of three people said
they got a lot closer with their
neighbors
dakota
what is your neighbors like who are they
and what's your relationship with them
one neighbor i don't talk to and then
the other neighbor is jimmy kimmel i
love him i love him too and i don't know
his wife molly is amazing okay so those
are great neighbors are amazing
neighbors except they have a lot of
parties and they don't invite me
is this for real because you know people
have gotten in trouble for claiming not
being invited to your party
that was amazing by the
way like amazing
we've got a fascinating fact that we
just learned about uh
well another hero of all of ours um and
someone you worked intimately with oprah
uh people reports that she recently went
on hoda's podcast to reveal that when it
comes to friends the magic number is
three
oprah says she doesn't have a lot of
friends it's just gail maria schreiber
and her trainer bob green
um lisa what do you think about this
magic three number with your colleague
oprah well it's funny because i did work
for oprah for a long time and it was
hard to imagine being friends with her
because i just i was so in awe of her
and i just i would just stare at her and
she would probably not want to be
friends with someone like me because i
was creeping her out
all of my friends
um i have more than three
but they are 40 30 and 20 years in the
making
today's pick for the little yellow book
is one for anyone who likes to keep
their hands clean as well as their
conscience
it's blue land's mickey and friends hand
soap kit it's an 18 investment but
here's what you get
a glass bottle that you permanently keep
and then you get the little refills and
what i love about this is i'm a big blue
land fan they're one of my favorite
environmentally conscientious brands
but this is a great way to get your kids
thinking in the right direction this is
a great
time
to get your kids started on
planet saving tips so this is planet
saving because you're making in a glass
jar you keep you're not throwing away
the plastic
soap container right i am so awake when
it comes to plastic and trying to find
the alternatives because i want there to
be a planet for my kids and i think this
is just a great optimistic fun way to do
it
[Music]
you